things are blowing up for you you're the
stand-up special
you've got uh the circle you've you've
been working in some
film you did a film with jlo just before
kovid what was that like what's she like
oh my i don't even know how to describe
jlo in
like five words or less she's amazing
she's
you know a mogul an athlete a dancer a
singer a mother
she's a boss and she has so much energy
she makes me feel bad about myself like
even in between takes
home girls like doing dance routines and
squats i'm like
isn't this the time we're just supposed
to like sit and listen to someone but
she still wants to like get a workout in
and even during lunch when you come back
from lunch i'm like what'd you do
what'd you eat and she's like oh i just
did the choreography for the super bowl
what'd you do and i'm like
i had a beyond burger i thought i was
making a good decision i think you're
putting yourself down having beyond
burger takes some thought and some
planning
so who's to say who accomplished more
yes
yeah yeah i mean you've met jlo i'm sure
you guys
years and years and years ago we had a
fling briefly and it didn't work out
because apparently i was imagining it
[Music]
that's the main reason it didn't really
work out
you know i have to ask you your netflix
special is hilarious but there's one
moment
that really made me laugh where you
are uh telling a joke it's really funny
uh but it's a little risque it's not
even a little risque it's pretty risque
and then they cut to your mom in the
audience
and her reaction is fantastic can i show
that now
oh please all right let's take a look at
this uh this clip
and and the cutaway to your mom let's
take a look let me tell you something if
you're single you're single you can't
afford to travel you need a second with
some foreskin it feels like you're in
another country
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm sorry she looks like she's having a
very painful treatment you know
it looks she looks very it's the rough
part of the pedicure right now
she's like i'm supposed to be enjoying
this but i'm not it's painful
and those are actually her friends next
to her so there are older people there
that enjoy
that kind of humor yeah but it's hot
it's
you know being such a
sex-positive comedian um with such a
caribbean catholic mother
is um interesting because she is
supportive
but we'll say what she's got to say
without saying anything you know she'll
be like oh you like that kind of stuff
yeah is this is this the reactions that
you've been getting because i imagine
when i see this cutaway to your mom and
i see her reaction
i picture this as being this has been
your life your life has been
you saying stuff uh and then her
reaction
has been what we just saw oh my god
conan are you my therapist i'm gonna
give you five out of five on zoc doc you
were just
reading the room that's exactly right my
mom is quite conservative she would
always wear black my whole childhood
same with my dad my dad were really dark
glasses too everyone thought he was my
bodyguard i didn't see his eyes so i was
like eight years old
and my mom barely talks i don't even
know she spoke english so i was like
five
wow so you know to be such an expressive
child
to have this is like really funny but
it's also
it makes me who i am and i'm you know
yeah i've also
i have a question which is um i have
found
that my parents are very catholic
there's a lot we don't talk about
at our house but i can say things on
television or on stage
that i could never say to them but then
i
i know that they're watching so it's
this weird dynamic
of i could i would never say any of
those things in my house
in front of my parents but if i'm on
stage even if i know they're in the
audience
and i i can kind of tell myself to
forget that i can
say things that i would never say while
they're in the uh
in the crowd which is a very strange
dynamic like what is it about being on
stage that enables you to be
that michelle and maybe less repressed
i guess it's being the version of
yourself an extension of yourself that
you've always wanted to be
right and so because i'm doing it on
stage in front of people
i'm assuming that they're probably
telling themselves it's not real
you know because you are different with
your friends than you are with your
partner than you are with your
co-workers and you are with your
family and so you are who you are
on stage right and so you know i'm just
a big titty kiki here for the fun a
bloated freckled face just
trying to have everybody you know loving
love on each other
love your body parts let's talk about
there's no shame in it but it would be a
difficult conversation to have at
thanksgiving dinner
i tried and so i think also making money
helps
you know especially with catholic
parents yes yes
the minute the minute my parents
realized that i was paying my own rent
they didn't care if i was a hitman for
the mafia
you know it just like yeah he's hey he's
paying his rent
yeah i know but he kills people he's
good at it he's killing a lot of people
and he's getting paid exactly he found
his niche
he found his market michelle that was
great that was really good thank you
before i go
my mom is in town visiting
from florida we are vax and waxed
mom come say hi to conan we were making
fun of you are you serious
i'm serious oh my gosh hi how are you
i can't believe you're doing this to me
how are you
thank you okay uh i love seeing you in
the special it's very nice when they cut
to the audience
and no i was not expecting that no i can
tell
i can tell you know but i tell you
something that's the face my mother
makes when i try to be funny
she doesn't like it she wants me to
behave myself
i know she it's always the dick jokes
conan what are we going to do
she always would say when i would be
anything she would just be like i want
you to behave yourself
and if i would tell a joke that she
didn't like she would say i don't like
that
i don't i guess all is the mothers right
yes the mother is the boss you are the
boss and it's your job
to look after michelle and you boss her
and you make sure she knows
she's going through my mail for me she's
amazing
i think she's embezzling bye mom